[Applaudissements]
jacques rullier ah mais oui je suis le
fils de boccace après un démarrage et
tous les blancs qui sont ici on
d'essayer de noircir mon père dans une
affaire pas très brillantes mais je vais
vous dire je suis en france présentement
pour faire mes études de président de la
république je travaille le soir au noir
la tour je leur dis je j'aime me
promener dans la rue avec mon père
lorsque soudain sous nos yeux exorbités
et quartier apparue une blonde pulpeuse
laddh de jeudi à mon père alors on la
bouffe tout de suite me dit non et
imbéciles on la ramène à la maison et on
bouffe ta mère tu attends attends
attends pas toujours dans l'avion en
acier qui nous emmenait à roissy charles
de gaulle l'avion j'avais une petite
faim alors je demande la liste de
passagers
elad joignez le douanier mouloudji et
taiwan à jesse ouanna tient le passeport
oui c'est le passé pas les remarquer
ceci là non moi j'ai dit oui vous
rigolez pas d'un signe particulier voir
photo dc une photo en noir et blanc là
je dis oui j'avais pas la couleur bon
sexe trop atteints ado il me dit vous
pourriez enlevez vos lunettes de soleil
quand vous me parlez là ce ne sont pas
mes lunettes ce sont mes narines
attends attends attends l'autriche dans
la rencontre et mon amie on nourrit il
avait dans les bras un énorme tournant
là qu'est ce que tu fous avec ce thème
ont présentement honoré disent aimer
voir le médecin
je dis oui mais pourquoi avec le
tournant présentement honoré il est
médecin m'a dit de revenir dans six mois
avec mais julie et l'avait aussi
attachée autour du cou à la place du
cubi habituel il avait un énorme
suppositoire qu'est ce que tu vois avec
le suppositoire présentement où nous les
îles disent les médecins
il m'a dit de suspendre le traitement
nous les a brigué nous les noirs quand
nous aurons pris le pouvoir
nous ferons comme c'est marqué dans le
grand livre nous mettrons tous les
blancs dans la montagne aglagla les
blancs et les jaunes la plus cotée les
rues la tripoter c'est marqué dans le
grand livre
si tu veux réussir il faut battre les
jaunes et montez les blancs en neige
[Applaudissements]